[Music]
and too much news too much submitted my
hello from Canada hello what's top 10
horas to Moines a man overdosed on an
erectile dysfunction drug and he now
permanently cease when like the color
red the color red so he's just only red
huh well that's all that blood and [ __ ]
oh is that what it is cuz it's a dilator
a vasodilator a vasodilator yeah yeah so
you just have boners in the entire body
you know the Cyclops now looks like
she's red oh he only sees red yeah cuz
the glasses he has lasers he sheesh I
wonder if he could get glasses that like
change that color and balance it out
like 3d glasses Oh like it's color
correcting like it's green lenses oh
yeah yeah yeah
is he in pain though I'm not sure so
they're just saying that this dude he
took a [ __ ] ton of erectile-dysfunction
meds I had the sex of his lifetime just
feel him all stiff now cuz his whole
body's a [ __ ] Boulder wouldn't mind
feeling like that imagine like when you
have a boner right it's just only in the
front but imagine if your whole body was
just connected like that they could
whole body but your dick you just so
you're just so [ __ ] horny you're just
like oh [ __ ] the wall
that means your whole body becomes a
dick and you're sensitive everywhere the
head with the latest yeah no there's
more work guys and girls take it your
entire body how you jack each other off
you you hug each other beg you both take
the pill and then you going like this
yeah that's just like oh yeah
what's the difference between ecstasy
and dick pills if the whole body big
pill whole body big pill I'm kind of
down to try both of them at the same
time but I don't want to die I know why
he's down because when you take ecstasy
you don't you can't get a boner he wants
to get the boundary action yeah he wants
to get the belt worth on ecstasy I think
that's one when I die cuz you're doing
two opposite yeah just blowed somewhere
I'm [ __ ] spleens gonna burst they do
do it yeah I've actually read about in
the forums but then there's a lot of
people that go to the hospital to
because they [ __ ] up I do come across
these forums yeah we don't ask them any
questions okay I was researching
it's for a comedy show yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah for research and by the way it
doesn't work okay
I don't know why I don't know why I know
this you know what you know young people
that take the pill and then they their
dick doesn't work anymore that [ __ ]
scares me that's what I'm scared I'll be
like I'm gonna just wait till the
appropriate age yeah the recommended age
you know what's weird is he always said
it's a room
that's amazing
David what's super app cyclomatic that's
what I'm gonna have a wait to the
appropriate age I gotta be the sensible
one you guys are [ __ ] stupid so I
have to be the level-headed one you know
mezzo made up country is a level-headed
let me tell you this though
why do people take too many pills that's
over the recommended dosage that's
stupid I think Oh like I ain't a [ __ ]
and then you take more isn't it cause
he's not with [ __ ] meds if the
recommended things is like five
milligrams I don't go that's how stupid
people are the only thing I do that with
is [ __ ] a tunnel in like a bowl
alright if you take more than the rectum
your stomach lining is gonna descend if
you have like serious pain you know if
you get like legit ibuprofen like the
one you get at the doctors those things
were like [ __ ] 600 800 ella grams
yeah but that's because the doctor said
I should be taken down yeah but I'm
saying like if you don't want to go for
like a prescription it's already 800
when you get it from the doctor
prescribe yeah well the dumb one the
pill is about like 200 to 150 well
you're not a doctor David you don't know
the dose but he gets caught in his own
shitty start studying but it still makes
sense to be people die on tylenol if you
are prescribed about 800 milligrams
right no doctor prescribes that for any
type of pain if you just take 300
ibuprofen there's not a specific type of
penis ibuprofen you guys are all stupid
your argument is valid but its raw be
doing but there's no idea you're right
and we were gonna validate arm is in a
cast you shouldn't be taking the same
amount of painkillers if you're not in
the cast about this how about this I
just don't want to feel anything at all
there's people that die from it I'm
worried David don't do that anymore
every hundred milligrams
from 300 possible so many times now how
many times have I broken something
fracture something come on every week
every week yeah come on come on I know
what I mean he's a gold member kids
listen to me that bottle is a
recommendation I'm fine I recommend lots
of water sleep and good old TLC for that
body thank you that's all you gotta do
I'll take pills take three times I get
the recommended dosage I get recommended
dosage and I throw it away you want to
hear a [ __ ] crazy ass story so
there's this dude I don't put him on
blast but he was a pretty big hot lifter
in the day and what he told me like what
he likes is he's squatting like 700
pounds on the daily so he doesn't like
feeling that pain on his body but he
does like the strength that he gets from
it so he always pounds painkillers
before every lifting session so he
doesn't feel jack [ __ ] but he pounds it
so much that he has a tolerance to it so
he has to switch up his regimen so if
he's squatting in the morning he's
taking excedrin then at night he's
taking tylenol then tomorrow he's taking
ibuprofen and that other night he's like
taking aspirin and he switches it up all
the time so he keeps his body guessing
he's addicted what a little [ __ ] know
there was research that said that if you
power lift or do exercise on painkillers
it's like it does the opposite of what
you want like you don't I have no idea
feel properly like I'm sure dude I have
no idea but that's what he that's what
he takes I guess be successful sounds
like a smart man I'm just like what does
that actually do it just bends your
blood right I don't know I feel like
I've read articles where it's like don't
take ibuprofen before you go work out
you know what I like that article but
I'm gonna do the opposite yeah I'm
afraid of pills me too not me unless
it's making me going dude here you the
31 year old healthy me my god he went it
was dead
no it's not dead he's seeing red
yeah dance is he angry Allah or is equal
is horny red horse I dream Radek when
you're no green is horny right grins
jealous Oh jealous it was a greed greed
green oh my god why is this matter in
colours ya know so anyways I came went
to the hospital after complaining that
he couldn't see properly and he took
this drug that he bought from online it
was like a liquid form of this erectile
dysfunction drug he drank the liquid
directly from the bottle so he doesn't
know how much oh my god he ended up OD
he got retinol toxicity which is an eye
disorder that affects how a person sees
color so now he only sees red oh I'd be
so mad if I can see is it permanent or
is it temporary for now they're saying
then Terminix there's no treatment for
it
Oh what do you got a hard dick though
hey be pretty awesome though if he was
racist and all now all these C's is red
that is amazing gonna be shades of red
that's awesome no oh look at you talk in
the room Jorge chocolate cherry people
oh that's right you can also still see
how small people's eyes are too until
they made it real they're more like
orange cuz they're already yellow orange
orange yeah
no but it's crazy so the fact that he
bought this drug online from a non
pharmacy source look at they're saying
that there's this one 2011 study that
found that 77% of viagra pills sold by
22 pharmacy websites were counterfeit
77% easy so the FDA is like telling
people do not buy off-brand by that girl
there's so many people with a broken
dick I think people just like the [ __ ]
around this one you think they want to
stay hard like for a long time even
though they're hard already yeah maybe
they want to have they want to last
longer you just need to learn tantric
sex my friends
do you know tender Thanks no I get tired
you know he does that what is it called
edging
was that what he trains himself right
yeah
what's edging it like where you were you
right about to come and you go and you
start doing karate forms and then you
start getting back into it right but
when you're about to [ __ ] you pull out
your neighbors must be so [ __ ]
confused it looks really nice I do that
naturally huh I do that naturally I
don't want to come yet
yeah so you like have to stop you got to
practice a lot but it's stressful though
what's that called
Lamaze yeah he starts doing Lamaze
that's what he's practicing just use a
[ __ ] condom yeah yeah we do at the
last second yeah yeah where's the last
moment I know but Khan does make you
less so much longer don't worry about it
does not feel as good oh for sure but
it's less stress is stress free though
you're so responsible I have to be
because I just don't want a little
bastard you know even child child even
if I do have a condom though I'll still
try to like pull out and last long I
don't want it doesn't it so the thing
that guys I don't know if they
understand it's not worth it for me
because like sometimes it's like you're
spending all this like one minute going
and then stopping and then what a minute
going it's not like I'm never gonna get
anywhere doing that for me I know this
is a very selfish thing so like you're
trying to last long for the girl or
whatever like that it's the best thing
for a girl then I think if he just comes
first gets it out of the way that we
could try again and he won't he'll be if
I come I'm going to sleep you know I do
all the time you come a lot there's like
yeah but every time we do it though you
get to finish this is a Jacke condom
that's really great that's not nice Oh
point zero zero three it's super thin
and actually feels really good you got
tell the truth I feel the same but it's
good enough I want to hear them not your
Japanese huh I just want him to
understand that you could be safe what
that's gonna solve your problem why
promotable condom it's gonna last longer
for himself exactly that's why that that
Bing is finding up where it feels good
for you but it helps you last longer
helps you
I don't know because this it
desensitizes just a little bit have you
guys ever tried this maybe I should try
this get numbing cream squirt it into
the condom oh no I'm gonna put the
condom on oh my god so that way you
don't feel [ __ ] why would you be hard
yeah I think you wouldn't get hard yeah
like you wouldn't feel like that's like
taking the joy out of sex just make your
dick hella soft I just try to squeeze it
in bake this okay I I'm a big this
sugarless cake it's just gonna be bread
with [ __ ] white frosty with no sugar
the [ __ ] half sob dick it's gonna
it's gonna work don't worry about it
harden there I swear it is don't want to
take viagra and then it gets hard to
that's a pretty hot though huh when it's
like half soft and then it gets hard
that's pretty hot damages the ego for
sure like it's like this yeah it's gonna
damage my ego it's like this in the
condom
is it getting softer inside the textures
we have to get out yeah
[Music]